au sommaire une balade équestre un peu
spécial un voyage dans le temps en
calèche la curiosité de la semaine un
métier séculaire le maréchal ferrant
rendez-vous à saint-andré depuis la zone
commerciale de la cocoteraie prendre en
direction de la ravine creuse pour
retrouver l'amicale des cavaliers de
l'est pour cette randonnée en calèche
c'est le cheval qui travaillent vous
n'aurez donc pas besoin de matériel
spécifique mais prévoir de quoi vous
protéger du soleil et une réserve d'eau
n'est jamais superflu
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
mode de transport privilégié d'un autre
temps la calèche fait son grand retour
sur nos chemins aujourd'hui loisirs
sportifs l'attelage est la solution
idéale pour découvrir l'équitation toute
sécurité sans l'appréhension de monter à
cheval
comme toujours lorsque l'on s'apprête à
partir en randonnée équestre la
préparation des montures se doit d'être
minutieuse et lorsqu'il s'agit comme
aujourd'hui d'ateliers une calèche les
réglages sont encore plus nombreux qu'il
faut vraiment que la mesure soit bien
posée au niveau des épaules ici pour
qu'ils puissent tractée et tirer
correctement ils peuvent tirer jusqu'à 6
fois leur poids pour un cheval
tirer et pas porter les chevaux doivent
aussi être équipés de hyères pour ne pas
être distrait et commettre des cars sur
la route les derniers réglages effectués
la calèche peut maintenant être atteler
il ne reste plus qu'à installer les
grelots qui préviendront les gens de
l'arrivée de la calèche hindous carillon
qui attire aussi les enfants du club
le
jeu
avec deux attelage en simple et en
double c'est un véritable convoi qui
part à l'assaut des champs de canne
un espace où les calèches d'accélérer
aisément sensations fortes garanties
qui
assis à l'avant de la calèche le meneur
et le pilote c'est lui qui conduit
l'attelage et qui décide de la direction
et de la lure seul maître à bord il ne
doit jamais quitté son poste sans faire
descendre ses passagers au préalable
derrière la calèche le groom qu'on
appelle aussi le singe reste debout pour
assurer l'équilibré c'est lui qui doit
descendre pour les traversées de routes
ou d'obstacles
arrivé en ville la modernité des
bâtiments et des routes goudronnées
tranche avec ce spectacle tout droite
surgi d'un autre temps une anachronique
qui attise la curiosité des habitants du
quartier
curieuse sensation que de déambuler au
milieu des voitures la ville défilent
plus lentement comme si le temps
ralentissez
ap
après une dernière traversée dans les
champs de canne nous voici pourtant déjà
de retour au club mais avec des images
plein la tête
on a fait surtout la découverte de
l'attelage réellement parce que il y en
a il ya des gens qui peuvent pas
forcément monter à cheval donc fait de
la rando attelage c'est accessible à
tout le monde 2 0 jusqu'à 77 ans c'est
vrai que la plage à la réunion se
développe réellement depuis maintenant
trois ans on fait déjà des concours
d'attelage ont fait des mariages aussi
on emmène aussi le père noël voire les
petits enfants c'est festif parce que
bon on traverse les villes on a le droit
de circuler sur la route réellement donc
on peut côtoyer les voitures on peut
côtoyer beaucoup de gens en on travaille
à 100 sur les routes c'est vrai que
quand les gens ils voient et ben on
revient dans le temps d'antan voilà on
on n'a pas de vapeur on n'a pas de
gasoil donc on roule justement on roule
grâce à l'énergie de notre cheval c'est
toujours les mais vainement c'est
l'émerveillement des gens qui nous donne
toujours envie de revenir au même
endroit et puis de l'art expliqué mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire tout ça c'est
vraiment l'envi
ce métier aussi semble tout droit surgi
d'un autre temps perpétuant des gestes
plusieurs fois séculaire le maréchal
ferrant de l'amicale des cavaliers de
l'est et notre curiosité de la semaine
métier de maréchal-ferrant sais c'est le
fait que vu que les chevaux maintenant
on travaille avec pour le loisir donc du
travail ils ont des sabots qui s'usent
donc pour éviter que des chevaux boîte
ils ont pu de pied on met des faire donc
on devait faire le cheval on enlève les
rives est ce qu on appelle l arrivée c
les ploucs on rompt donc on rabat à la
fin ensuite on fait chauffer le faire et
on a juste le faire au pied du cheval
c'est pour ça qu'on fera chaud et à
froid c'est pas possible de faire un
style correctement
à l'état naturel c'est pas compliqué le
cheval travaillent pas ils se déplacent
juste pour manger et boire donc ça s'use
au fur à mesure que ça pousse donc ça se
règle
je suis fier de mon métier je suis fier
maréchal ferrant c'est pas courant et je
suis content techniquement parlant on
n'a rien changé du tout dans le métier
depuis des lustres il ya quelque chose
qui a changé maintenant c'est leur taupe
et 10 grâce aux radios à l'échographie
donc on arrive à voir maintenant ce qui
se passe dans pieds
ils vont lui aura jamais ce métier-là
pas possible il faut pas pas une machine
ferrer un cheval ça c'est niet